Speaker 1: Many of you wrote to me and you
said, David, sir, I'm a big, strong guy, but
I have tears in my eyes as those stories often
go, because as I looked through this gay marriage
bill that just passed, it's not really clear
that it actually guarantees gay marriage.
And those people are absolutely correct.
Absolutely correct.
And so I want to talk about that.
The reporting widespread from over the weekend
and late last week, Bill, to protect same
sex marriage rights clears Congress.
The idea here was let's codify gay marriage
before maybe Republicans come for it.
And the Supreme Court makes a decision on
gay marriage like they did with Roe v Wade.
We have seen many on the right say the gay
marriage decision was just as wrongly decided
by a prior Supreme Court, as was Roe v Wade,
making it clear they are setting their sights
and targeting gay marriage as well as a whole,
but access to contraception and other things
as well.
So the idea was let's codify it, let's guarantee
gay marriage.
And indeed, the House on Thursday, as The
New York Times writes, gave final approval
to legislation to mandate federal recognition
for same sex marriages.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
What does that mean?
The vote was 258 to 169 with one member voting
present.
This now goes to Joe Biden, who will, of course,
sign it.
I don't want to sort of like sugarcoat this
or dance around it.
The legislation doesn't require states to
issue marriage licenses for same sex couples.
That is not what the legislation does.
States currently have to do that because of
the 2015 decision from the Supreme Court.
If that decision were overturned, even despite
this legislation, states would no longer have
to issue same sex marriages.
What the law says is that states that that
all states must recognize same sex marriages
that were entered into someplace else.
So let me give you the exact scenario.
Imagine now that gay marriage has been codified,
even though it hasn't really.
Now that this law has passed, imagine that
in a year or in two years or whenever there
is a case that gets to the Supreme Court,
much like the case that ultimately overturned
Roe v Wade, gets to the Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court does decide, hey, it was
wrongly decided.
It was wrongly decided.
So we're doing away with the 2015 decision
that made gay marriage that banned bans on
same sex marriage.
Does this new law mean that if Kentucky doesn't
want to anymore, they have to issue same sex
marriage licenses?
No, it doesn't.
All this law says is that if the 2015 gay
marriage decision is overturned, Kentucky
would have to recognize same sex marriages
from wherever.
So you wouldn't be able to deny a gay couple
married elsewhere all of the same rights that
married people have in Kentucky.
But it does not mean that Kentucky would have
to issue same sex marriage licenses if the.
2015 decision is overturned.
So it's better than nothing.
But at the same time, if people don't have
money to travel in order to get married somewhere
else, it's going to create problems.
It's going to create problems for people.
It doesn't guarantee gay marriage to anyone.
It guarantees if you find a place to get married,
it will have to be a recognized marriage in
all 50 states.
And again, this is all preemptive.
It's if the 2015 decision were to be overturned,
that is what it does.
And that is what it does not do.
Is it better than nothing?
Of course it is.
Is it not really that great?
If the issue is, let's make sure that no matter
what happens, gay and lesbian couples will
continue being able to get married in any
state.
Yeah, it doesn't do that.
It absolutely doesn't do that.
It is what it is important to understand it.
Now we know what it is and we press forward.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
Remember that the David Pakman show is an
independent media program.
It's not like the sort of stuff you get when
you turn on your TV and watch cable, for example.
We actually depend on the support of our audience
to do what we do.
The best way, the most direct way, the way
where we keep the most pennies out of every
dollar is when you sign up at join Pacman
dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members.
We provide a commercial free audio and video
stream for our members and we also do members
only town hall events, the next of which is
coming very, very soon.
Sign up and join pacman dot com.
You can use the coupon code 24 starts now
to get yourself a tidy little discount